dream street singer Chris Truesdale has
died he was 34 years old
according to TMZ the ex boy band member
died Tuesday night at a hospital in
Burbank California due to complications
from kovat 19 a statement posted to his
verified Twitter account read quote he
was alight to so many and will be missed
dearly by his family friends and fans
all over the world Chris joined the band
in 1999 along with Jesse McCartney Greg
raposo Matt bellanger and Frankie
Galasso several of whom were scouted
from the NYC acting and theater scene
including Chris who had a successful
career on Broadway as a child actor
on Wednesday Jesse took to Instagram to
mourn the death of his former bandmate
writing quote Chris had an explosively
charming personality with boundless
amounts of talent the group lasted only
a few years before they broke up in 2002
Chris went on to have a solo career with
features on place I'm gonna make you
love me as well as Nicky Cleary's cover
of you're the one that I want he also
guest-starred on Disney shows like
Austin and Ally and shake it up in 2012
Chris auditioned for the voice feeling
this whole thing again over just brings
back so many memories that I've kind of
thought I would never find again or have
the opportunity to do again you know
it's um it's overwhelming but didn't
make it past the third blind audition
round
[Music]
[Music]
you